autour du 15 octobre je me souviens des
cinquante ans après la crise d'octobre 5
big man n'auriez oublier l'ancien doyen
du collège universitaire saint jean de
milton se rappelle en particulier de
groupes de jeunes qui a pu lier
ouvertement le flq lors d'un congrès
étudiant en octobre 1970 ined annoncé
l'acteur mesure de gars je pense c'était
le même jour là sur la police
gendarmerie et appliquent connaissance
de ce qui s'était passé et là ils ont
arrêté l'étudiant de cela comme partout
la jeunesse franco albertaine de
l'époque contestataires y la gendarmerie
royale du canada suit de près les
mouvements étudiants la police
gendarmerie royale m'interviewer survenu
dans le monde bureau pour me parler
d'eux est ce qu'il y avait des militants
du flq à l'intérieur de nos étudiants ce
qu'il y avait un problème face à l'acte
des mesures de guerre si une poignée
d'étudiants sont sympathiques aux idées
du flq
on sait de la francophonie canadienne
majoritairement fédéraliste la crise
d'octobre provoque de vives réactions
souligne ce professeur d'histoire qu'on
n'y pas d'accord avec cette violence là
et ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on veux
mentionner notamment dans les journaux
de l'époque dans la francophonie
canadienne qu'on condamne la violence et
qu'on veut continuer d'y aller avec le
ton de la démocratie de la bonne entente
nous voulons respecter la langue des
deux principales communautés
linguistiques du pays
les francophones qui viennent d'obtenir
du gouvernement de pierre elliott
trudeau la loi sur les langues
officielles l'année précédente craignent
désormais que leurs revendications
soient associées à celles du effectué
et on veut continuer à dialoguer avec le
fédéral qui est un ami et que la
réputation des canadiens français des
francophones de l'alberta de la
saskatchewan du manitoba de l'ontario
soit intacte
donc on veut pas nuire aux relations
qu'on est en train de bâtir avec les
fédérales le sujet ici délicat que la
publication du manifeste eut effectué
dans les pages du franco albertaine 21
octobre 1970 peut provoquer le
congédiement de son rédacteur en chef la
semaine suivante
ça va créer une mini commotion dans la
communauté parce qu'on se dit qu'elle
manque de délicatesse qui est d'avoir
publié s'est manifesté là et on le voit
comme un appui à la violence de la part
du rédacteur en chef vous franco
albertain pour les étudiants ça a été un
peu plus intimidant un demi siècle après
les visites de la grc fin de mes gamins
juillet de ne pas avoir été trop
intimidés mais les arrestations quand
même laissé des cicatrices n'a jamais
été une accusation comme tel le taiso
l'homme était accusé de crime ça a été
assez traumatisant pour les étudiants
une facette de la crise d'octobre encore
méconnu qui rappelle que ces événements
marquants ont tout n'est pas partout au
pays
ici mathieu gaye i radio canada à
edmonton